I got some from my girlfriend the other
night I haven't gotten in years I got
the old blue balls oh yeah nothing fun
about that you know what I'm talking
about
I hate the blue balls the worst part
about it she's like what is that what is
blue balls I don't get it can you
explain it to me what is that and the
only way I can explain it to her
the only way I could make her get it
was by saying
hey here what happened to Susie
no I can't say
and she was like whatever she was like
look I can't she's like what you can't
just start it up like look I can't she's
like please please I'll do anything I'm
like that's blue balls
that's it right there sister
That's Why They Call It The Blues
one thing I never got about
relationships and uh I'm on the lady
side of this one I never got these guys
who complain about their girlfriends
when it's that time of the month
I got to see a little cranky for a week
they're seeing a little Moody
you do realize that means you're not a
father right
seems like a pretty good trade to me
I love the period bring on the
menstruation I say you know when my
girlfriend gets her period it's that
same feeling like
right after you pay the rent
you know you're like this month
is gonna be fine
love that
thank God
any ladies menstruating right now
I'll take that as a yes all right good
luck boyfriends
[Applause]